quand tu poses des choix quand tu agis
au quotidien et que tu adoptes certains
comportements ont sciemment ou
inconsciemment tu te réfères à des
valeurs les valeurs nous semblent être
des réalités très subjective et donc peu
susceptible de faire l'objet d'une
modélisation c'est surtout qu'elles sont
nombreuses et variées pourtant les
valeurs ont été étudiées pendant plus de
trente ans par le psychologue social
shalom schwarz qui a réussi à proposer
un modèle de valeur non seulement
intéressant d'un point de vue théorique
mais qui surtout a été validée
empiriquement par de nombreuses
observations je te mets d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des références liées à son
travail dans la description de la vidéo
je m'appelle sylvain draps mais je suis
professeur de sciences sociales en
belgique et sur cette chaîne de la
société ge 2 propose des vulgarisation
des grandes théories des sciences
sociales ainsi que de la méthodologie de
recherche dans cette vidéo je te
présente l'ensemble de la théorie des
valeurs humaines de base j'ai déjà
réalisé une vidéo sur les normes et les
valeurs que renvoie vers cette vidéo si
tu souhaites jusque une introduction sur
ses concerts car cette vidéo ci est un
peu plus poussés à et je te met la vidéo
sur les normes et les valeurs en fiche
maintenant je te proposerait aussi plus
loin dans la vidéo un questionnaire qui
te permettra d'identifier les valeurs de
base ont le plus d'importance pour toi
on en profite pour t'inviter de ta bonne
et à la chaîne et d'activer la cloche
afin de ne pas manquer les prochaines
vidéos consacrées aux grandes théories
des sciences sociales avant de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet il convient d'abord
de définir ce qu'est une valeur shalom
schwarz propose six caractéristiques
propres valeurs qui les différencie des
normes ou d'autres concepts des sciences
sociales une valeur est tout d'abord une
croyance une représentation sociale qui
est activée dans certaines situations
cette croyance constitue un objectif
général désirable qui oriente nos
actions et transcende le contexte dans
lequel nous agissons en lui donnant du
sens les valeurs nous servent souvent
inconsciemment de repères et de critères
pour évaluer les différents éléments et
les comportements ou les événements qui
surviennent autour de nous elles sont
liées rares chizé et l'on préfère
certaines valeurs à d'autres nous les
classons dans un certain ordre de
préférence enfin c'est la mise en
relation et les tensions des différentes
valeurs qui influencent nos attitudes et
nos comportements par exemple le plaisir
peut être une valeur importante pour toi
si tu estimes que le but de la vie et de
profiter de satisfaction personnel
immédiate quel que soit le type
d'activité la recherche de plaisir sera
à la base des choix et si une action te
procure beaucoup de souffrance tue la
jurade négativement même si elle peut
être importante pour ton avenir par
exemple mais tu peux aussi estimé que
faire des choses déplaisantes n'est pas
si négatif que ça même si le plaisir est
le plus important pour toi car juste
derrière celui ci lui accorde beaucoup
de valeur à la solidarité tu peux donc
accepter des tâches peu amusante si
celles ci sont utiles au groupe auquel
tu appartiens tu ne veux pas laisser
tomber tes amis ta famille tes collègues
même si cela te coûte du plaisir on le
voit bien ici les valeurs auraient entre
nos actions bien qu'elles soient
hiérarchisées
elles sont en tension et en interactions
au sein du processus même de décision la
théorie des valeurs de base postule
qu'il existe un certain nombre de
familles de valeur et que toutes les
valeurs peuvent être regroupées et sont
liées au sein de cet ensemble que shalom
choir snom les valeurs de base le nombre
de valeurs de base a évolué au fil de
ses recherches il en a d'abord proposé 7
pour monter à 11 et en a finalement
retenu dix que voici autonomy
stimulation hédonisme réussite pouvoir
sécurité conformité tradition
bienveillance et universalisme je ne
vais pas les détails et tout ici mais je
te propose ce tableau dans lequel tu
trouveras toutes les valeurs qui sont
inventoriés dans ses valeurs de base
si certaines valeurs te parle mêlant
commentaires afin que l'on puisse
identifier les valeurs les plus
importantes pour toutes celles et ceux
qui suivent cette chaîne ce qui est très
intéressant avec ses dix valeurs
fondamentales c'est que leurs relations
sont structurées et qu'elles connaissent
des antagonismes ou des compatibilités
les unes avec les autres par exemple la
valeur de réussite entre souvent en
opposition avec la valeur de
bienveillance quand nous poursuivons un
but relatifs à notre succès personnel
nous avons tendance à négliger un peu
plus lente reds où le partage par contre
la visée de la réussite est compatible
avec la volonté de pouvoir un autre
exemple est celui de la recherche de
stimulation qui pousse ces individus à
traquer la nouveauté et le changement et
qui se posent au respect des traditions
et des coutumes en revanche la tradition
est soluble dans une autre valeur qui
est la conformité dans ces exemples
certaines valeurs de base satire tandis
que d'autres se repoussent challenge
charles modélise c'est compatibilité et
antagonismes en effet il propose une
représentation circulaire dans laquelle
chaque valeur occupe un espace l'espace
occupé par chaque valeur est à proximité
des espaces occupés par les valeurs
compatibles sera à l'opposé des valeurs
antagonistes en fait cette
représentation permet également de
dégager deux astres structure le premier
axe est construit sur l'opposition entre
ouverture au changement et continuité
une conservation les deux pôles de la
seconde dimension sont l'affirmation de
soi et le dépassement de soi c'est à
dire une opposition entre intérêts
personnels et ouverture aux autres la
structure circulaire nous permet de
comprendre le découpage de cet espace
des motivations il faut percevoir les
valeurs comme distribués de manière
continue et constituant des gradients en
relation avec les valeurs voisines les
découpages de son juste alors que des
tiroirs dans lesquels on classe chaque
espace à ce stade le ou la plus critique
pour affirmer que cette théorie des
valeurs fondamentales est une bien belle
et séduisante théorie mais qu'il ne
s'agit là que d'une vue de l'esprit
[Musique]
qui pourrait facilement être contredites
ce serait là une grave erreur que tu
penses là car shalom schwarz va réaliser
de très nombreuses observations pour
confirmer son modèle empiriquement il a
utilisé deux types de questionnaires
pour enquêter
un premier questionnaire comporte 56 ou
57 items présentant chacun un aspect
d'une des valeurs de base par exemple
l'un de ces items et égalité comme
chances égales pour tous situés dans une
valeur de base universalisme un autre et
plaisir satisfaction des désirs
appartenant à la valeur hédonisme les
personnes interrogées sont priés de se
positionner par rapport à chaque item
elles doivent noter sur une échelle de
neuf points l'importance et l'influencé
de chaque item sur sa propre vie sur
base des réponses formulées une moyenne
individuelle a été calculé en regroupant
tous les items d'une même valeur de base
des huit précédemment mais un problème
de méthodologie se posent certains
individus pourrait donner des notes
globalement élevé tandis que d'autres
seraient plus prudent et plus économe
dans la distribution des notes à comment
faire dès lors pour lever ce biais est
bien ciblé l'importance relative que les
individus accorte aux différentes
valeurs car ce qui nous importe c'est la
place que la valeur occupe dans la vie
et les motivations de chacun et non le
score en lui même qui n'est au final
qu'un indicateur la solution est assez
simple la correction est effectué en
centrant les réponses des participants à
l'anc est à partir de leurs notes
moyennes à l'ensemble des valeurs de
cette manière on utilise les écarts
relatifs à cette moyenne plutôt que les
notes brut un second questionnaire a été
construit à la suite du premier afin de
pouvoir réaliser lé enquête auprès d'un
public peut-être moins à l'aise avec l'
approche très conceptuel et abstraite du
premier exercez-vous une activité
professionnelle ça dépend oui là
évidemment on vous demande de répondre
par oui ou par non alors ça dépend ça
département au pense aux enfants aux
personnes âgées mais aussi aux personnes
issues de cultures moins proche avec les
modes de pensée occidentaux ce
questionnaire propose 40 portraits qui
décrivent des personnes imaginaire par
exemple c'est important pour cette
personne d'avoir des idées nouvelles et
d'être créatif il ou elle aime faire les
choses à sa façon de manière originale
bien c'est une description pour une
personne qui valorise l'autonomie les
répondants sont invités à se positionner
par rapport à ces portraits via la
question jusqu'à quel point cette
personne et elle comme vous en devenant
l'une des réponses suivantes tout à fait
comme moi comme moi un peu comme moi un
petit peu comme moi et pas du tout comme
moi de laquelle on déduit l'importance
accordée par la personne à la valeur
correspondante le traitement de ces
données constituent une mécanique
incroyable shalom schwarz calcule le
coefficient de corrélation de personnes
entre 56 valeur sur base des chiffres
obtenus en fait ils calculent le lien
statistique qui existe entre les valeurs
cette opération permet de chiffrer la
liaison qui existe entre deux variables
en mesurant le degré de dépendance entre
elles par exemple si un coefficient de
corrélation entre deux valeurs est
proche de 1 cela signifie que les deux
valeurs varient en même temps de la même
façon quand l'une varie d'une certaine
manière l'autre suite quand le
coefficient est proche de zéro c'est
qu'il n'ya aucune correspondance tandis
qu'un coefficient proche de - 1 indique
que les variables évoluent dans des
directions opposées lorsque la première
croix la seconde décroît d'une manière
équivalente tu veux en savoir plus sur
les corrélations je te mets différents
liens vers d'autres vidéos dans le
descriptif ci dessous une fois que les
coefficients de corrélation son calcul
entre chaque valeur celles ci sont
reportés sur un espace en deux
dimensions les items qui sont
objectivement liés seront positionnés à
proximité les uns les autres et seront
soignés des items qui leur sont posées
autrement dit cette projection permet de
visualiser les cohérences qui se dégage
de l'observation empirique est ce que
l'on obtient est remarquable car si l'on
replace chaque item dans les valeurs
universelles on voit que dix ans semble
correspondre aux valeurs de base
identifié théoriquement sont bien
présents et que la structure de l'espace
est elle aussi ce qui avait été proposé
qui plus est on constate que l'ensemble
de l'espace est occupé ce qui signifie
que toutes les valeurs de base sont
couvertes bien sûr les découpages des
populations restent arbitraire mais la
structure et l'organisation des valeurs
est un fait shalom schwarz a recueilli
avec ces outils des données dont 68 pays
au travers de 233 échantillons ce qui
représente un total de 64 1728 personnes
interrogées les résultats sont
surprenants puisque en dépit des
cultures des ajouts des catégories
sociales on retrouve à peu de choses
près la même hiérarchie des valeurs pour
l'ensemble de la société concernée même
si les variations entre les personnes
existe les valeurs de bienveillance
d'universalisme et d'autonomie arrive en
tête de la hiérarchie tandis que le
pouvoir et de stimulation ferme la
marche il explique cette stabilité entre
les cultures par le fait que les trois
valeurs de tête sont les valeurs utiles
à stabilité des groupes et des
collectivités et que dès lors les agents
de socialisation ainsi que les agents
qui assurent le contrôle social favorise
l'intégration le maintien et le respect
de ses valeurs alors que les valeurs
moins plébiscités par les répondants
sont des valeurs qui peuvent mener au
conflit interpersonnel et menacer la
cohésion des groupes ne seront pas
favorisé comme les premières et sont
donc moins valorisé socialement tout ce
qui vient d'être dit n'empêche pas
l'existence de différences
interpersonnelles je lui ai déjà dit
comment les valeurs de base sont elles
intégrées et hiérarchisé par les
différentes catégories de personnes qui
constituent une population au niveau de
l'âge les études empiriques montrent
qu'avec celui ci les valeurs de
continuité à savoir la tradition la
conformité et la sécurité prenne le
dessus sur les valeurs d'ouverture aux
changements que sont les de nice mme la
stimulation et l'autonomie il en va de
même pour les valeurs d'affirmation de
soi le pouvoir et la réussite qui laisse
la place aux valeurs de dépassement de
soi la bienveillance et l'universalisme
concernant le sexe il existe quelques
différences entre les hommes plus enclin
à privilégier le pouvoir et la réussite
et les femmes qui favorise les valeurs
altruistes mais de toutes les variables
tester le sexe n'est pas celle qui
introduit le plus de variation le niveau
d'éducation joue assez bien sûr
l'intériorisation nom de certaines
valeurs selon l'indicateur du nombre
d'années d'études on constate que ce
dernier explique en partie la
prédominance des valeurs d'autonomie et
de stimulation au détriment des valeurs
de conformité de tradition et de
sécurité avec un meilleur niveau
d'éducation les individus remède plus
souvent en question l'ordre établi enfin
un revenu élevé pour le ménage auquel on
appartient autorise un certain optimisme
et un esprit d'ouverture à vie en
général la raison pour laquelle les
personnes issues des ménages les plus
aisés ont tendance à accepter les
valeurs de stimulation d'hédonisme et de
dépassements le pouvoir est
particulièrement présent dans le tiers
de la population ayant les revenus les
plus élevés comme on peut s'y attendre
ces personnes sont également moins
réceptive aux valeurs de tradition de
sécurité et de conformité la théorie de
shalom schwarz a été et est encore très
féconde d'abord au niveau pratique ou la
théorie des valeurs peut apporter des
clés de lecture et permettre
l'intervention efficace dans différents
contextes je lisais d'ailleurs récemment
un dossier relatif à la gestion des
groupes classes dans les écoles où
l'auteur luc peters préconisé de
recourir à ce modèle pour cibler les
différences de hiérarchisation des
valeurs entre les élèves et les
enseignants une trop grande différence
pour être à la base de
dysfonctionnements dans les activités
d'enseignement et d'apprentissage
mais la théorie qui a été présentée ici
a été mobilisé à de nombreuses reprises
dans des recherches et notamment des
études comportementales visant à montrer
l'importance des valeurs dans les
schémas d'action des individus par
exemple en sociologie électorale lors
des élections italienne de 2001 on a
vérifié que les électeurs italiens de
centre droit était plus réceptifs aux
valeurs de sécurité de pouvoir et de
réussite que les électeurs de centre
gauche lorientais surtout vers la
bienveillance et l'universalisme cette
théorie des valeurs de shalom schwarz et
donc à mon avis incontournable si tu
souhaites utilisé ce concept de valeur
dans sa recherche de sciences sociales
je t'avais promis un questionnaire pour
évaluer ta propre hiérarchie des valeurs
tu le trouveras dans le descriptif
n'hésitent pas à y répondre et à venir
partager tes résultats dans les
commentaires de cette vidéo je te
remercie pour ton attention et pour le
soutien que tu pourra accorder à cette
chaîne et je te dis à très bientôt dans
une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]